Pulitzer Prizes and the National
Humanities medal socialize with
America's most prominent political and
cultural figures including JFK Marilyn
Monroe and Norman Mailer he kept a
journal of his experiences with entries
from 1952 to 2000 next you'll hear from
his former colleagues on the recently
published journals this is just under an
hour I'd like to introduce all three
speakers now and then I'll get out of
the way on the first is Eric Foner the
duet Clinton professor of American
history at Columbia University and
someone I know needs a little
introduction eric is a prize-winning
teacher he's the winner of many many
academic honors and awards and the
author of many books including perhaps
most famously his reconstruction
America's unfinished business which was
a winner of the Bancroft prize
he is currently finishing an edited
volume of essays about Abraham Lincoln
with contributions from a dozen or so
major scholars and this volume will
appear late in 2008 in time for the
Lincoln bicentennial year our second
speaker is David Nassau the Arthur M
Schlesinger jr. professor of history at
the Graduate Center of the City
University of New York he too of course
is an award-winning scholar and teacher
and the author of many books most
recently his volume I sure that most of
you are familiar with on Andrew Carnegie
which was published by Penguin in 2006
his writings have also appeared in The
New Yorker and the nation and many other
periodicals and I particularly want to
mention that he is chairing a program in
honor of Arthur Schlessinger on October
15th 11 days from now at the Graduate
Center of the City University of New
York it will have an array of speakers
including Eric Foner
appearing again Alan Brinkley Sean
Wilentz and others that program on the
15th will be from 6:00 to 8:00 p.m. at
the Graduate Center 34th and Fifth
Avenue here in New York the third of our
speakers is Louise mirror of course
known to everyone here in this room is
president and CEO of the New York
Historical
and formerly executive vice-chancellor
of the City University of New York but
she is also a major scholar and author a
medievalist and early modernist best
known for her book women Jews and
Muslims in the texts of reconquest
castile instead of standing here where
she normally would Louise
today joins in the program drawing on
her kinship with Arthur not only is a
fellow public historian but as a
longtime friend and next-door neighbor
here in New York each of our
participants will give I will read a
passage or two from Arthur's journals
and offer some reflections about his
life and legacy
so let's begin alright do you want to
sit there come on
thank you thank you Jim Baskar I am
going to leave the personal anecdotes so
to speak about author to the others
mostly because I didn't actually know
him that well until toward the very end
of his life although I knew his
scholarship throughout my career as a
historian and admired it for many many
years of course the last time I spoke to
Arthur Schlessinger was back in early
this year when I was able to tell him I
called to tell him that the Society of
American Historians
which I was serving at that time as
president of that organization had voted
to establish a new prize for lifetime
distinguished accomplishments in history
in his name the author slays injure jr.
Prize and it would and he was very very
gratified to learn that of course he
would have really been the best first
recipient to that prize but probably
that wouldn't have been creek in any way
but what what interests me about the
about the journals which I certainly
recommend to everybody to read because
it's such a fascinating glimpse of
American politics as social life and
just at a remarkable intellect writing
about what was going on in this half
century that
the journals cover the the the passages
that I chose to read really the first a
couple focus really on Arthur's
liberalism he was a public intellectual
of course he was also actively engaged
in American politics sometimes at the
very highest levels when he was serving
with the Kennedy administration and then
briefly with the Johnson administration
as a you know major adviser and very
often with political campaigns going way
back to the Adlai Stevenson this this
begins in 1952 and what struck me at the
very beginning really was the picture we
get of Adlai Stevenson in this book and
what it tells us about the sort of
liberal intellectuals like author or
like my own mentor Richard Hofstadter
who were so enthusiastic in the 1950s
about Adlai Stevenson frankly I never
could really understand why actually and
reading the journals is a very interest
in his comments on Stevenson is very
interesting because author himself kind
of realized that Stevenson wasn't really
a liberal at all actually even though he
still was enthusiastic about him I just
want to read you a couple of passages
about about Stevenson from early on in
aa want the kind of thinks about the
political campaign he's involved in but
in the front page 12 he met with him in
Springfield Illinois this is in 1952
right around the time that the Stevenson
is nominated as Democratic candidate for
president to run against Eisenhower my
jet this is author my general reaction
on leaving Springfield was that's Adlai
was probably even more conservative than
I had thought perhaps indeed at this
stage the most conservative Democratic
candidate since John W Davis I will
leave it to these scholars in the
audience to try to remember who John W
Davis is or when he actually ran for
president but it was earlier on in the
century his campaign seems currently
oriented toward two groups one the
high-minded Republic
who the Stevenson people seem to think
could be one away from Ike and to
Eisenhower to the southerners for whom
solicitude is fairly constant for both
these groups one can emphasize the
issues of foreign policy and to some
degree civil liberties but economic and
social reform clearly must be muted so
in effect he's supporting a candidate
who doesn't want to talk about the
issues that are really of concern to
author economic reforms social reform
and and civil rights
Slazenger had been involved previously
in the great struggle of the civil
rights in the late 1940s in the
Democratic Party but now with the
nomination of Stevenson the Democratic
Party fundamentally turned its back on
the whole civil rights struggle in 1952
and in fact they put a rank
segregationist Sparkman on as Stevens's
running mate so author is kind of he
says I left Springfield thinking I would
be lucky if I could get the candidate to
mention the New Deal in the course of
the campaign so he didn't and so we
didn't think that Stevens in what but
nonetheless he supported him use enthuse
because if Stevenson was his kind of guy
he was kind of bookish he was
intellectual Eisenhower seemed to these
liberal you know historians is just not
the kind of guy who want to be President
but but it's just interesting how he saw
through in a sense some of the failings
of Stevenson which never really came out
in public but then in it four years
later Stevenson again is running as the
Democratic candidate against Eisenhower
and slated here again meets with
Stevenson to talk about civil rights on
civil rights he kept saying that the
basic fact was the difficulty of
adjustment it was raising false hopes to
suggest that people's hearts and minds
could be changed by coercion the Negro
leaders are defeating their own purposes
when they put on pressure the only Negro
hope is to reduce tension and let the
moderate minded southerners assume local
leadership now this is 56 the Montgomery
bus
boycott that is already underway the
Supreme Court decision of 54 has already
been issued Stevenson has no conception
really of what is going on i slays
injure pointed out to all this that the
Negroes had never gotten anywhere except
through putting on pressure and they
knew it also that if he proposed to be a
voice of moderation it must be a two-way
voice he must explain to the South why
it's resistance seems shameful to the
north and to most of the free world he
expected the Negroes to be reasonable
but not the white Southerners and this
seemed to me unfair I don't know what
impact I if any I had I think he
conceded that his appeal to the Negroes
for moderation could succeed only if he
first laid the basis by demonstrating
concern over their problems
so again civil rights you know was not
really a concern of Stephenson's laysurs
trying to push this from behind the
scenes and as I say I think these
opening pages to me offer a very
interesting view of the problems of the
kind of liberalism that slays and he was
pushing for in the 1950s then let's just
jump in my remaining time a decade
further into the 1960s and of course he
serves with the Kennedy administration
President Kennedy of course as we know
is assassinated he stays for a while
with Johnson by 1967 author is out of
the government and is more and more
deeply concerned about the escalation of
the war in Vietnam and this leads him
actually to a very interesting
reflection in here this is April 1967
not only about the Vietnam War
but about the whole nature of the
liberalism that he has been promoting
along with a lot of others which is so
much based on a strong president and in
fact in his scholarly writing the
Jackson the Roosevelt he identifies with
the strong reform minded president
changing things from the top
Johnson is escalating the Vietnam War
this is what slays and just says
the irony is that is that all of us for
years have been defending the
presidential prerogative and regarding
Congress as a drag on policy they wanted
that strong leader it is evident now
that this delight in a strong presidency
was based on the fact that up to now all
strong presidents have pursued policies
of which one has approved in other words
you like them you like strong presidents
when you do it when they're doing what
you think is right when they don't you
may not like them we are now confronted
by the anomaly of a strong president
using these arguments to pursue a course
which so far as I can see can lead only
to disaster it is not hard to assert a
congressional role but given the
structure of the American system it is
very hard to see how the Congress can
restrain the presidential drive toward
the enlargement of the war voting
against military appropriations as both
humanly and politically self-defeating
the only hope is to organize a broad
political movement and even this cannot
take effect until at the very earliest
1968 which may be too late this is 40
years ago and I hardly need to say that
the exact same dilemma faces our country
right today a strong president leading
the country into disaster and Congress
unable effectively to do anything about
it and so what's interesting is Slade
you really changed in reflecting his
notion of how liberal change should come
about the only hope is to organize a
broad political movement not just rely
on those you know in office to bring
about reform and I do know that at the
very end of his life he was sort of
hoping that such a movement would also
emerge in this country 40 years later to
combat the same fundamental problem
anyway thank you very much for listening
and I'll turn the podium over
thank you I'm going to stay here too
long a walk when I moved to the Graduate
Center as the chair of the history
department there Arthur was already
close to retirement he could have held
on longer as to many of his colleagues
who collected a paycheck and in so doing
block the appointment of a replacement
but he did not he retired from active
teaching but he continued to use his
office advise students and participate
in all sorts of events at the Graduate
Center in for the Graduate Center room
for the students he arrived at the
Graduate Center which was then on 42nd
Street late in the morning usually look
through his mail and retreated to his
large corner office never in my life
have I seen anything quite like that
office
Arthur dressed neatly wrote neatly spoke
neatly and accurately appeared to be
well organized Alexandra is she knows
what's going appeared to be well
organized in every facet of his being
except his office as a historian he
never wanted to throw anything away it
was evidence of something and you would
walk into his office and it was a
disaster it was like 46 teenage boys had
been in there uh it was it was more than
a disaster it was a health hazard and if
if Arthur had not been nimble on his on
his feet he never would have been able
to skirt the piles that were hanging off
bookshelves desks tables piles of books
of manuscripts of ashtrays of mementos
of gifts that have been sent him when he
spoke somewhere what surprised and
delighted me I was surprised by his
office but I was surprised and the
I did by how open he was to everyone
here was probably one of the most
recognizable men in New York certainly
the most recognizable man professor
anywhere um and students could knock on
his door it was knocked on his door and
hope that no one was going to answer
they could knock on his door and be
ushered into this office and if they
could find the place to sit sit down and
and artha would talk to them and answer
questions and give them ideas for
research and just continue the
conversation
he never it appeared turned anyone away
and never gave anyone less than his full
attention because he couldn't do much in
his in his office when he was
interviewed on camera he would bring the
camera crews down the hall to where we
had a conference room and sometimes it
would be the BBC sometimes it would be
NBC sometimes it would be a high school
journalist from Des Moines or someone
from you know Iceland or Belgium who
wanted to talk to him and he gave
everybody the same attention whether the
camera was on whether the camera was off
no matter where you came from he would
sit down and talk to you and and he
wouldn't talk to you in the way of
giving a wrote rehearsed answer to
whatever you said he would look at you
he would think about the question and he
would answer it his influence on his
colleagues not just in the history
department but at the entire Graduate
Center was just overwhelming uh he was
an extraordinary colleague even after
his retirement when he was asked to give
a talk to incoming students or to sit in
on a class that happened to be talking
about the Kennedy administration I mean
he arrived
he was there he would never plead Oh
like again like to many of our
colleagues he would never say oh I I've
got a deadline to me or I've got to go
home and write uh he never backed off
he was always open that was part of his
not his job his vocation as a historian
he established for all of us a model of
engaged scholarship his ability to
transcend the stale dichotomy of the
Academy in the outside world of you know
the ivory tower and the nasty little
world outside of it was was
extraordinary that dichotomy didn't
exist for him he was as comfortable
talking to a high school class as a
professional organization or writing an
op-ed to writing an article in the
political science quarterly he was the
embodiment of what would later come to
be known as the public intellectual
which has become a badly overused term
today because we don't have Arthur
Schlesinger 'he's among us what was
important about him as a public
intellectual was that he refused
absolutely refused to compromise to
water down to simplify his scholarship
when he spoke a rote to an audience
outside the Academy he was you know he
was Arthur Schlesinger he had done all
this work he had done all this thinking
and he wasn't going to give one group
you know the a treatment in another
group the D treatment too often
academics pay less attention to the
dissemination then to the construction
of their understandings their analyses
their contributions to scholarship this
was not the case with him he labored
mightily and unselfconsciously to keep
alive the notion of history as a
literary art he wrote for himself he
wrote for his colleagues he wrote for
the scholarly community he wrote for
posterity and he wrote for the largest
possible
public and we learned from this we
learned that it was not only desirable
but more importantly it was possible to
be a scholar to be an academic and to
speak and write for other academics and
for a larger audience and coming out of
graduate school that was a revelation
and an inspiration for a bunch of us but
there was more still more that Arthur
taught us he taught us within the
Academy and within history departments
he taught us humility his favorite
warning to students and to his
colleagues was that they had to remember
we had to remember that history wasn't
written it was rewritten that there's no
final truth available to the historians
that we must do the best we can knowing
that those who will follow will have
other questions to ask of the material
and other answers and other
interpretations and other conclusions
you know for the last 20 years the
discourse theorists in post modernists
have been saying this in gussied-up
language well you know Arthur said it
directly and he practiced it last
October we held the symposium at the
Graduate Center it was one of Arthur's
last public events on the history of the
Jacksonian era Sean Wilentz had written
a new book that was going to that in
many ways took issue in many ways
confirm but in some ways took issue with
what author had done 50 years before in
his great book on the Jacksonian era uh
Arthur was delighted to get up on stage
and to say I'm happy that John has gone
a step further the problem was that he
was suffering at the time from
Parkinson's disease he could barely
speak most of the time above a whisper
and he was getting a little shaky on his
feet we suggested to him that Erich who
was on the panel that Erik read his
comments and he said well
won't be able to decipher my handwriting
and I stopped myself I said you still
write out everything instead of of
course so we we engaged we got his
handwriting we deciphered it we
transcribed it we sent it back to him he
made some Corrections because he never
stopped working on whatever it was he
was writing came back we typed it up
eric was all prepared to get up and to
read these remarks and at I guess it was
at the end of the evening
Arthur was sitting there up on that like
we are today and it came time and autumn
pulled himself up and he walked over to
the podium and he delivered in this
strong strong voice this brilliant
brilliant talk about the duty of the
historian to rewrite and to understand
that he was going to be rewritten as we
read his journals we see this humility
this understanding that individuals
don't write history by themselves or for
themselves Arthur never tried to fit
events into some pre established
framework he never assumed he had the
answer to the unfolding of events let me
give one example from his journals and
it's an example that that Eric also
picked up on during the Kennedy years
the journals are filled and I recommend
these to everyone whatever you're you
know whatever you like to read it's in
here it is an incredible read in the
Kennedy years in here Arthur decries the
weakening of the presidency and says why
can't we have a stronger president and
then the next two presidents to follow
he thinks are a little daft and he gives
good examples when we end up reading of
we too will worry and wonder how we got
through the Johnson years in the Nixon
years in May
of 1972 just after Nixon had delivered
an ultimatum to Hanoi and Moscow and
announced his intention to mine the
North Vietnamese harbors Arthur was
called Washington to testify before the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee quote
though the subject of the inquiry was of
course historical the senators also the
witnesses were so filled with present
apprehension that the CAW talk kept
turning to the Nixon speech the senators
were in a state of intense frustration
and kept asking what we the historians
thought they could do to prevent the
historian from further the president
from further escalation one suggestions
were laying he's talking about himself
fun cutoff this that one can only
understand their sense of impotence and
their rage Nixon has gone further I
guess than any president in ignoring
even the forms of congressional
consultation and here's and here's where
we get Arthur the humility I fear that
those uncritical theories of the strong
presidency that historians and political
scientists myself among them were
propagating with such enthusiasm in the
50s have come home to roost in the end
author was a historian first last always
and that's why on October 15th we're
going to celebrate him as a historian
with a group of historians at the at the
Graduate Center at six o'clock he tried
to take the long view to understand
rather than to condemn to listen rather
than to lecture to historic eyes events
place them in context and always try to
figure out why his enemies and opponents
acted as they did his relationship with
my generation of new leftists
not with me was contentious and often
overheated but he was more tolerant of
their ideas than they or we were of his
I want to read a passage from May of
1970 in the midst of the horrors of the
Vietnam War and protests Arthur to
Sunday night you have to remember as I
read this that Arthur was among other
things film critic one of his problems
with JFK it's in here is the JFK always
walked out of the films that author
chose and wanted him wanted him to see
and and at one point author said to JFK
do you mind that I write film criticism
and JFK said no but just be kind to
Peter Peter Lawford his brother-in-law
okay so uh to set this up Alexandra and
Arthur are going to reprieve you a
preview of Antonioni's film Zabriskie
point I haven't seen it in a long time
but I don't know if I want to quote it
is a hymn to violence and revolution
done in the most heavy-handed and
simple-minded way in the course of the
film
I became vaguely aware of mutters in the
row behind and in awhile I began to feel
that the mutters were directed towards
me towards the end of the movie a large
house is blown up as a sort of metaphor
of revolution the explosion is repeated
a number of times and finally I
whispered to Alexandra this is the film
that ought to have been called lower
this produced an angry reaction from the
row behind the next scene Shone's books
and other artifacts hurled into the air
by the explosion from the row behind
there goes birds were history
in another moment the film was over and
the house lights went on a young jerk in
the row behind suddenly launched a
tirade what are you doing watching this
film he began it's about you and your
kind and what we're going to do to you
it's a disgrace that you should have
come to see it well that you can walk
the streets at all and we're going to
fix that and very soon we're going to
rub you out these incredible sentiments
uttered in rather shrill tones love it
had an arresting effect for several
Isles around I started to answer with a
man I mean you couldn't make this stuff
up I hope it's not made-up I started to
answer with a man in the leather jacket
who had been sitting next to me suddenly
intervened he turned to the
revolutionary and said you shut up
when the revolutionary kept on talking
the men in the leather jacket said have
you ever heard of the Abraham Lincoln
brigades and he proceeded to lecture the
young revolutionary about the special
Civil War the Abraham Lincoln brigades
and what true revolutionaries do and
don't do in the end Arthur said it is
not untypical in these days that this
kind of New Left revolutionary bring
together members of the old left who
previously might have been deeply
divided over the merits of things like
communism and then just two months late
after that in May of twenty may six and
I won't read this but I will tell you
all to write it down and you go read it
yourselves on page 324 right just three
months after this he goes into this
paragraph in which he explains the
laughs and he says I understand why
they're going crazy I understand why
they're angry he said there were the
assassinations then they elected Johnson
I mean I'm sorry there were the
assassinations then there was Nixon and
Cambodia they were the Johnson
escalations he said the experience of my
generation who had we had the luck to
have FDR this generation doesn't have
that for them quote the democratic
process has been a sham and a phony and
they react accordingly
[Applause]
good evening I'm really delighted to be
a part of this extraordinary gathering
of friends family and fans of Arthur
Schlesinger jr. Arthur was a great
friend of the New York Historical
Society and along with his wife
Alexandra who I'm thrilled is here with
us this evening
he was my next-door neighbor in Beekman
place in a book of such extraordinary
breaths as journals it wasn't easy for
me to make a collection of passages to
read today so in perhaps videos and
kradic and certainly self-indulgent
style I thought I'd choose to read a
passage from the year I was born 1953 as
it happens that year consists of the
shortest entry in the entire book in a
sea of really fascinating recollections
it appears that the year of my birth was
for Arthur very dull indeed it's good to
be humbled every once in a while I
decided to move on to 1954 and wish I
have to admit mark for the first time
that I was slightly younger in 1964
Arthur's brilliance as a historian and
his brilliance as a writer
able to convey the sense of a
conversation as if the reader were a
vibrant part of it in right now the
here-and-now are in fulsol flower so in
this year he records one of the nation's
most shameful periods the faith he
describes in the American people should
hearten and fortify all of us in
troubled times today I arrived in
Chicago
Saturday evening September 12th after
registering at the Congress I went over
to the Conrad Hilton and located some
newspaperman sorry I'm going to change
this slide put my marker on the wrong
page once again President Truman came to
town today to address a fundraising
lunch for the Truman library I had 15
minutes to talk with him in the morning
in his suite at the Sheraton Plaza we
talked considerably about McCarthy he
then began to muse about the incidence
of periods of hysteria in American
history he told me as he had before that
he had completed a monograph on this
subject as he figures it the periodicity
is about eight to ten years thus from
the Alien and Sedition Acts to the trial
of Aaron Burr the know-nothing an anti
abolitionist sentiment to the 50s
reconstruction through the election of
1876 from a mitchell Palmer to the
campaign of 1928 so he guess is that it
will take McCarthyism eight to ten years
to burn itself out which means anywhere
from 1956 to 1960 before it is over but
he affirmed both touchingly and
impressively his face in the decency of
the American people and their capacity
to recover from these binges of fear and
panic HST looked very well trim natty
and cheerful as usual I want to read a
second passage because as the neighbor
and fell a member of Beekman place
association in which Arthur was active
my most vivid recollections linked him
to his
wonderful wife Alexandra I live in a
little maze net whose living room window
did double duty as a Vista on to one of
New York's most beautiful Blanc's and as
a portal onto an extraordinary couple
who watch together on our Street daily
sometimes many times daily Arthur's
admiration and affection for Alexandra
is reflected in his many references to
her in the journals including this
passage from 2000 on the 31st we went to
Washington to see the new millennium in
arriving in time for luncheon with
Robert I had been surprised to receive
the invitation for New Year's Eve at the
White House in the Clinton years
we have never been asked to a state
dinner we have dined twice at the White
House once at a farewell dinner for
Pamela Harriman on her way to Paris Pam
put our names on a guest list and once
that a dinner for Arts and Humanities
medalists as a medallist I had to be
invited both times though I was seated
next to Hillary alexandra thinks
probably correctly that we owe our
invitation this time to George Stevens
who is co-producing the ball any Alinta
tainment with Quincy Jones we stated the
hay-adams and made our way to the White
House around 6 o'clock a reporter asked
me how I would sum up the last
millennium I said I'm glad it's over
a long talk a hour follow during which
we were astonished by how few of the
other guests we even recognized I
suppose most were big contributors we
talked to Chris Dodd in his charming new
wife Jed and Vicky and Jean Kennedy the
Fred Dutton the Bob's runs a few others
at dinner Alexandre sitting between Alan
Greenspan chairman of the Federal
Reserve and Jill Wolfensohn president of
the World Bank held for a moment the
financial future of the world in her
hand Greenspan whom I have known
slightly for years has been much
humanized by his marriage to Andrea
Mitchell he came over and taught
cordially to me for some minutes and
Alexandra found him an engaging dinner
partner Arthur Schlesinger jr. was not
only an exceptional scholar but also as
we've heard an exceedingly generous
person on a number of occasions I
delivered armloads of his books to his
home with a request to autograph them
for New York Historical Society members
and friends he never complained about
minor venus which was extreme at times
and he always delivered the goods arthur
honored us several times with his
presence at evenings just like this one
he was always always interesting
he also honored us by invoking a speech
given at the New York Historical Society
in 1868 in his much read and much cited
article in the New York Review of Books
in April 2006 in that article he writes
that and I quote history is not
self-executing
you do not put a coin in the slot and
have history come out it's a funny way
of putting it but as we know very true
Arthur concludes that article with a few
lines that are worth adding I think to
our Vedas this evening I quote this is
the endless fascination of historical
writing the search to reconstruct what
went before a quest illuminated by those
ever-changing prisms that can
can you replace old questions in a new
light as a great Dutch historian Peter
Gayle was fond of saying history is
indeed an argument without end that I
believe is why we love it so much we do
love history and we did love Arthur
Schlessinger jr. when mrs. intelligence
his wit and his friendship thank you
we're open to some questions for the
members of the panel from the audience
it's a it's a large book but I imagine a
lot has been edited in the preparation
of the journal is there any insight from
family members as to what and why mate
something was edited or not included
basically it was a Arizona from the
greater than 6,000 pages we had to cut
out around the 4/5 or 3/4 and an other
volume could be spun out of this but and
maybe they will but we concentrated on
the everything related to his political
life and political views and American
politics so there you go well we since
there are representatives of penguin
here maybe we can ask them if they feel
like publishing the other 5 volumes that
have not yet appeared in print I hope
they will
in the context of the dis uniting in the
view of America which is obviously a
diatribe against multiculturalism what
was the negative response if any in the
mail that showed up at the household
mail did show up in the house that who
here is pretty oh I'm sorry I'm assuming
there was a strong negative response
from any number of people and I was
wondering what it was yeah you know
there was the diss uniting of America
was one of our there was a great
columnist as well as scholar and when
some of his writing is very measured and
some of it is highly polemical does this
uniting view of America which was a book
published in the 90s I can't remember
exactly what year was as this gentleman
pointed out a attack on what was then
called multiculturalism and its impact
on the writing of history and on
intellectual life in general which he
thought as the title suggests was
fragmenting the society and fragmenting
intellectual processes and purposes and
I think it did there were a lot of
people who were very who took a very
different point of view very vocally and
there was a lot of debate in the
historical profession about whether this
critique was fully warranted etc what's
interesting is that later on I myself
heard ought to say that he actually
regretted a little bit the tone of that
book that he felt he had failed to sort
of indicate a kind of common ground that
some of the some of the writers he was
criticizing might actually have with
some of his earlier writing and that and
that he realized that there was another
danger to intellectual life coming from
the opposite side of the political
spectrum of people trying to kind of
create a switch you might call a
patriotically correct history which left
no room for all the diversity of
American society but there was you know
it was controversial but one thing that
I could say about authors he doesn't shy
from controversy
things as he saw them you know on the
October 15 event that Eric and I are
going to be at at the Graduate Center
David levering Lewis the extraordinary
historian is one of the people who's
taking part and I asked everyone to talk
about a particular book or passage from
a book that affected them and that
contributed to their better
understanding of what was going on
David levering Lewis is going to speak
on chose the dis uniting of of America
as you come to come to the session Neil
here my father goes into the destruction
of that in the diaries so you'll find
that quite interesting but one of his
comments was he wasn't sure he suddenly
for the first time in his life a lot of
conservatives were supporting his point
of view and he wanted her to see had
done you know what that was all about so
you can read a lot them I would like to
comment briefly on Eric Foner's reading
of the passages relating to Adlai
Stevenson on November 7th there'll be a
meeting here at the Historical Society
about Adlai Stevenson at five o'clock in
the afternoon and that will be a good
occasion that perhaps put it more
perspective well 10 or whatever those
comments reflected as to the caution
that conservative that Stevenson
reflected in democratic politics in 1952
I think the I think Arthur felt deeply
that no man who ever ran for the
presidency and wasn't elected had more
influence on the democratic processes in
our country than Adlai Stevenson did and
had greatly and profoundly influenced
the whole generation who then came to
power
later it and he very reluctantly not
reluctantly he made a very determined
judgment that Kennedy was a stronger
political candidate and he was not sure
that Kennedy was any more liberal than
certainly than Stevenson was but the
thing that I think held the Stephens
onions together and allowed Arthur to be
the leader of that movement was his
internationalism and in 1952 and 56 that
was a threatened aspect of America's
positions in the world and with the
McCarthy era itself and full gear in
1952 at least Evensen with his eloquence
managed to speak to the country in an
extraordinary way and and run a race
that nobody could have won against our
greatest national hero but at the same
time I think left a very profound mark
and the American politic and I think
after all of his life's help Stevenson
was not only a great friend but a very
important leader
mr. Schlesinger has said at times that
they regretted having spent so much of
his effort on public matters rather than
what he would consider his core work as
a historian is there any sense of how
strongly he felt along those lines and
related to that are there any subjects
that you think he might have gone into
that he hadn't because of these
distractions he does say in the journal
somewhere that he exactly what you said
that he's kind of pulled in so many
directions that he's frustrated that he
can't finish let's say his Roosevelt you
know his New Deal multi-volume study
which you know he was always wanted to
go back to that and he had so many
interests and so many responsibilities
and his hat is you know in politics and
public life movie reviewing whatever I
but you know but putting it but despite
that he made an enormous contribution to
the study of American history so even if
he didn't finish every single thing he
might have there aren't a lot of
historians who can claim such a body of
work that he actually produced and thank
God he didn't finish it all I mean it's
bad enough for those of us who are
historians today to look at this I think
it's 25 to 28 books and many of them 800
to a thousand pages we all knew about
that and we were put to shame by it and
then to discover that there were 6,000
pages more yeah that after writing it
right hand writing he would somewhere to
find the time to write lucid fluent
intelligent prose 6,000 pages of it
so Arthur complain now and again that
the final Roosevelt books weren't
finished and he yearly wanted to finish
the second volume of the of the memoirs
but he has left us with a leg you know
it's going to take a long
to fully evaluate this legacy this might
be a good juncture I think to ask Andrew
who not only member the family but one
of the editors of this volume and
accomplished this heroic production to
come up and make a few closing remarks
before we adjourn to continue outside
thank you the co-editor of these
journals my brother Steven is very sorry
that he could not be here tonight to
celebrate the publication of the
journals he had a long-standing
engagement in Idaho not with the senator
but at the request of the widow of
Senator Church to speak at the Frank
church Institute at Boise State
University on the topic of presidents
the Constitution and national security
now Stephen and I have had an exciting
time over the last 11 months ever since
my father's age and Andrew Wiley
discovered the journal on a shelf above
the refrigerator in my father's office
stuffed in dozens of file folders more
than 6,000 pages and we were given the
task of carving out of them this epic
narrative under enormous time pressure
as a publisher wanted to bring out the
journals as soon as possible in the
midst of the presidential campaign to
profit from the intensified interest in
in politics and public affairs of course
this version of the journals is
concentrated upon American politics over
the last half-century
the campaign's the conventions the
personalities the methods which my
father found so fascinating and
exhilarating I remember the day in
December when two large boxes arrived at
my doorstep in Cambridge with a fearsome
sudden as co-editors our job was not to
correct grammar or syntax each entry was
finally constructed and required no line
editing but to reduce the thousands of
pages of the journals by 3/4 or
four-fifths while respecting our
there's intents and purposes we were
indeed fortunate fortunate to be able to
consult with him in the months before
his death his general attitude
what the hell you have to call them as
you see them yes these journals were
written to be published one day our
Father knew he was recording the raw
materials of history there are no deep
psychological revelations here but there
are revealing and important observations
on famous events and larger-than-life
personalities as he wrote on May 3rd
1962 it is my historians conscience is
not any natural inclination which gets
me to the typewriter yet what a
collection of stories and anecdotes
entails he was able to recount what a
cast of characters so my brother and I
read morning noon and night
marking passages and entries trying to
hew closely to our themes conscious of
the epic sweep of the narrative then we
compared our selections and resolved our
differences and sent them over to Laura
Stickney and caught Scott lawyers at
penguin who contributed their own
suggestions and Eamonn Dacians Steven
and I discovered that we could work went
very well together I'm the younger
brother so that was good to find out and
other books can certainly be spun off
from these raw journals but my father's
world travels or relations with European
political and intellectual figures or
more on his engagement with American
culture movie theater New York City the
literary life history said the great
explainer of human affairs
Arthur's lazing or juniors journals 1952
to 2000 he passed away in 2007 mr.
Slater's journals were edited by his
sons and were recently published by
Penguin Group for more visit penguin